well I think it was Tom Wolfe credited
me with being a forefather in that
business
I never while he was flattering to me or
trying to be I never fully accepted it I
don't think it was new and I don't think
was journalism what it was what I'd like
to pretend to think it's is and can't
always be is defining reality in a way
that's verifiable and it's also
storytelling technique the storytellers
have have through our through our
literature been mostly fiction writers
and the fiction writers that means a
novelist or a short story writer or
playwright or a filmmaker our people who
are defining visually or or maybe
through prose are defining privacy they
are writing about private life which is
meaningful which we all can identify
with because the lives of those they're
writing about like the women of my
mother's stores back in the 40s are
representative of an atmosphere of a
time and the fiction writers whether
we're talking about mr. Tolstoy or mr.
Hemingway or we're talking about Joyce
Carol Oates or Philip Roth they're
writing about their time but they are
incorporating into their writing new
names or changing the place but it is
also not so much so that we can't say
that's really real like you can you can
read great fiction and you get a sense
of being there what I wanted to do what
I aspired to be even when I was 25 30
years old was to write short stories or
to write the book that seemed like it's
made up like a novel or full-length but
don't change the names and get to know
the characters so well I didn't have to
invent the characters I could use real
names real situations I could get from
knowing from hanging around hanging
around the art of hanging around so long
so
so comfortably part of another person's
ambience and personality and an
expectations that I could capture that
put it on paper and be sure to degree
that anything could be true this was the
true representation of the people I
wrote about and that might be called New
Journalism but it really wasn't New
Journalism it wasn't journalism it was
storytelling and the only thing that
made it different from ordinary
storytelling which is the province of
the fiction writer is it was not fiction
now there are writers that violate this
all the time I mean one of them like you
know James Fry's famous made-up memoir
exaggerated now he's written a novel
which is what he should be doing and
hopefully do again and again there are
people that are great at writing and
making it up and then we have to
celebrate them great writers but there
are people that can write very engaging
Lee and descriptively and not make it up
but that takes a lot of time because in
order to write knowingly about people
you have to spend time and you have to
spend so much time that sometimes you
feel you've lost your own sense of being
a writer because you don't publish if
you spent so much time on research it
could be three or four or five or six
years in which you don't even try to
write yours you're getting to know your
characters you're getting lost in the
tribes of literary quest and and and
then you have to then think I'm not I'm
not I'm not out there I'm off the radar
screen and in in terms of being known
and that is a period that very much is
it leads to depression sometimes but I
mean I'm not saying that I'm I'm not
without depression there are people
sometimes you think you'll never get
never get through this you'll never
finish you'll never finish you'll never
know enough you'll never be ready to
write and when you start writing you're
never good enough you're not getting it
right this whole process but I believe
if you finally do get it done to the
best of your ability it is a worthy
worthy endeavor because you were getting
a chunk of reality and you're putting it
in book form and it could be read in
2008 or
2029 or you know whatever 50 years from
now if it's any good it's gonna hold up
you